do you ever just sit down and do nothing
and just watch TV you know I watch a lot
of movies you do yeah I watch about a
movie a day I tried to a movie a day
yeah is that right yeah I love movies I
grew up loving movies and had jobs and
went to movies and well absolutely but
that's I mean what movies do you watch
and I grew up I got to make movies and
do you watch you don't watch your own
movies do you those are the only films
that I watch all of them
I just watch nothing but your own movie
what are you talking about it's me too
or like
no I watch I watch all the films that
come out my first apartment I had in New
York I just I didn't buy drapes or
anything like that I just I had the
biggest television that I could get yeah
with all of the systems LaserDisc and
VHS laserdist is my I I was one of the
investors of laser desk is that right
dude we both lost we both lost in that
deal